hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation we
just got back to the office where
weights was murdered horribly by aliens
now just gonna find out where he was
murdered horribly by aliens and how's
our friend in the jail cell doing I'm
sure he's doing just fine on the robot
Menace unless he somehow managed to
escape oh lucky summer he somehow
managed to escape good so I'm done seem
right ooh that's a nice painting of one
Adil robot menace I hope it doesn't come
alive and kill me this looks like a
lawyer's dream in here this is a
security console for the whole station
glad it's still fitting the retro theme
of technology here but I'm gonna move
along and try to find a dead body
because there's none here law has no
boundary I don't think that's a good
thing so I need to go probably over here
I'm trying to find wherever the hell
they went cuz there's no dead bodies
here there must be it's an interrogation
room for any suspect they have in space
space suspect oh oh there's a dead body
that's not wait so that's now weights
so where's weights hello wait a minute
where's my friend that's right I had a
friend in here in the medical Bay it's
my friend is somewhere in her she was
standing right there the one that got
shot in the side and where's my other
robot dude friend the not murder oh god
it's so pretty oh I hope I live long
enough to see Space Station's in space
did anyone write a last-minute message
before they died dear diary
ah the end okay error kind of parasite
oh wait I've already seen this before
I've already been through
I need to find him they're not here I
think they may have got clear Ricardo
Ricardo cycles can you run this place I
need eyes and ears I'm not [ __ ]
staying here Ricardo I need you to do
this can you man the station and keep me
covered
Ricardo yeah sure
cooks sit tight lock the [ __ ] doors
and don't let anyone in look after me
I'll come back from you okay [ __ ] just
got real real quick alright so the
Android Menace is alive and well but my
Android friend is probably alive also
but maybe if holo will make him crazy
and he'll go nuts oh and you'll be the
final boss or maybe he was behind it all
along maybe it was awful oh hi sorry did
not see you there oh yes actually there
is someone here but you said that weird
thing again I don't much care for you
there's no way to insta kill a robot is
there I just came off of playing a bunch
of evil within so I apologize if I
somehow mix-up the games oh good we're
back to the position where I need to go
through the shutters that are already
open so I need to go back the way I came
take the transit to the Simon Tower for
some reason I can't just take it
directly because everything is clear
enough Hey hey Ricardo man can you open
things for me no okay I'll go just go
generally the way I came
what's that oh it's fire
well that's creepy as hell
so weren't all those people go that why
is that guy running in place
that is a weird thing for a robot to do
you can't wait to get pumped up to kill
people which my life's purpose even
though you don't have life that's an
argument unto itself say so he's just
gonna do his little happy dance over
there and I'm gonna end his okay never
mind maybe I don't have to confront this
guy we he definitely won't hear this
rolling shutter go up okay bye
thank you sir I'm on my way I'm on my
way to try to find Samuel so I can get
an answer about this Apollo situation so
then they can know why the hell all the
robots are on a murderous rampage I mean
not that it doesn't make for a good game
but I mean good golly couldn't there be
some other way oh I went the wrong way
oh no oh no oh no oh no no no no the
wrong way I was right I could've gone ah
okay I'll be back in a second oh it's
just one over here okay here's where I
am I could almost hear the cacophony of
comments that were saying that I'm a
really smart person and handsome well
okay whoa I probably shouldn't be
running at the moment but without the
alien here willy-nilly run all I want
freedom as far as the eye can see I just
need to get by without wasting too many
bullets but I have a feeling I should be
able to run cool that's creepy the way
you're banging on that door okay
don't mind me I'm just gonna go
you shouldn't be anywhere cuz you should
be dead but I don't you don't hear me
talking about you that way there might
have been something over there that
spoke to open but I don't have time
Simon Tower this one so it's good right
okay bye bye
oh why see I was supposed to do that
well I'm gonna sneaky sneaky
you'll have to report what are you gonna
there's nothing to report breath there's
nothing to report when your turn to
watch your turn to die I'm just waiting
for the tram you're just falling over
but a good thing that I'm such a good
badass has arrived almost it's almost
here it's on its way
anybody wanna mess with me I'm gonna
save before the crash again just in case
cuz you never know when something
horrible is gonna happen busy and poor
game but I mean generally in life too
you never know when something horrible
good man like you never know when that
thing behind you is gonna stop staring
and you decide to act on its inhibition
its instinct to kill to maim I just
played a game also that you might see
soon called deep party simulator and was
a creepy bear in there but either way
enjoy that soon if it's not out already
I have no idea what I'm gonna release
I'm actually putting videos in the
stockpile so that I can go to Cincinnati
give you my charity livestream there and
see my family and my friends in that
order
I can't wait to go home I haven't been
to Cincinnati since I moved here maybe
once I don't remember dancing once
Ricardo I need to focus you're in charge
now focus Ricardo
if Samuels can talk to Apollo you can
get the androids to stand down then this
will all be over
yep because Samuels is a much more
advanced AI than they ever will be so he
doesn't have to worry about a damn thing
where am I supposed to go oh I went the
wrong way you misused the word everyone
out of this alive there's plenty of room
for pity if you just work together damn
it you'd be alive look at these body
bags right here's because they did not
work together they did not cooperate as
a team and that's why this is a valuable
lesson for everybody out there work as a
team or else an alien will rip out your
heart or burst through it
either way fun for the whole family
except for you so cooperate okay
that's Parker Blair's life lessons bar
bars life lessons for life good for the
heart
I've known so isn't this where the alien
first started almost destroying me when
I first discovered its concentrated
levels of douchiness maybe remember it's
where that douchey doctor decided to be
a fun guy I I seem to have a proclivity
proclivity to say the word douche I
should find a better word anyway so I'm
gonna get back in my way what that guy
so how do I get up let me write this
down because it's probably important
eight three eight two okay you got it oh
wait there's something else there yep
seeds and frail origins after Weyland
industries led the way in
faster-than-light travel seeks and found
success mass producing the flight
components central to the colonial Gold
Rush that followed its ensuing over
expansion and reputation for producing
low-cost alternatives to why w-w-why
branded goods as a matter of public
record
blah blah blah they are bad Sevastopol
is a ghost town and nobody cares cool
I'm glad that I'm here speaking of ghost
town there's a lot of dead people oh
wait there was another thing over there
I have no idea what happened to this it
seems like he got some magazine shoved
down it throat now I don't know that if
that's what killed him or if that's just
an accessory to the crime
either way fairly gruesome I don't know
what to say about it really I don't want
to go that way death oh god wait Samson
that you
okay that's obviously not Sampson
because this guy seems to be bleeding
and is also dead also has red blood and
I've killed so many of these robots why
is there oh this is where I first
learned that I could actually shoot oh
good I remember this I thought I killed
these guys then stuck in here for a
quick savor Rooney so that nobody can
sneak up behind me I have such a big
feeling that the alien that I jettisoned
into space or that weights jettisoned
with me with it is going to come back
somehow because of everyone who's
watched the aliens movie knows they
confirmed survive the vacuum of space
for like forever I don't even know if
they really eat they are nuts creatures
also I started looking up the art of H R
Giger or Geiger or I think it's geeker
he was the inspiration for the vast
majority of the art to do with it oh
wait how do I get to the elevator shaft
I'm going the wrong way for synthetic
processing I don't want to go that way
do I so I need to come back and I need
to go to the other I need to look at my
map more because I'm just moving through
this it's a problem because I've been
through these areas before so it kind of
gives me this false sense that I know
where I'm going because the station
can't be all that big
I mean it's Bayesian yeah good size
constraints and all that
it's still really cool but I mean I
can't be too fast and loose with where I
go there we go supposed to use Bob the
torch on this you can see how I could
have overlooked it but I need to pay
attention we okay my camera was going on
and slicey slicey slice and dice pop out
oh this is where any of the passcode
okay so eight three eight two you got it
man nobody would have been able to do
that except for me also where the heck
do I get my eye on towards cuz I would
like that I feel so much safer in these
vent in these vents without an alien was
that I do I got a bad feeling about this
I got a really good feeling about
everything that's going on right now oh
man nothing terrible can happen
nothing horrifying and awful can befall
me now everything is awesome everything
is cool when you're part of the team
everything is awesome when you're living
our dream music Simon
we're good we're good have fun wherever
the hell you're going oh okay Wow
guy if this one isn't going the same
donessa nation the destination is that
why I needed to go no other secret items
around here what why are there sounds
this reminds me of the elevator scene
from aliens deceit oh this is fun and
tasty this is crazy delicious okay I'm
probably supposed to go that way
I don't need that can I make another
Molotov maybe yes I can thank you very
much
Moby to move in the book I've got almost
maxed out of every single item I mean I
was really spamming him when I was
against the alien but now it's just the
robot menace I mean John Connor was a
bit of a Wimpy baby man if you ask me
these Android machines oh thank you
space butthole for letting me crawl
through okay man these Androids
this one's dead I would like to know
that Samuel I know I'm well aware of
this okay so I need it I have no
objective right now he's gonna jump out
at me I knew it I knew it I knew it get
dead get dead buddy I knew it I knew it
I called it what could I have done
differently I've tried to hit him before
I'm here looks like the place whew
that's cuz Samuels came through here and
wrecked house clean house wrecked [ __ ]
get get dead
looky that's only moderately creepy
she's still alive
he's dead
I got motion on my motion tracker
there's somebody nearby somebody need of
extreme prejudice list queuing no
prejudice prejudice full killing killing
with prejudice whatever the proper way
to sit you sassy sack of [ __ ] I will not
tolerate this young mannequin ass piece
of crap I don't much like you so who
killed all these was this Samuels please
tell me it was Samuels well let me just
toss them around like they were nothing
I really hope it was Sammy was by the
way time for the advanced synthetic to
make his way through here huh turn off
do I need to turn this off I don't
recall anybody telling me to turn this
off unless that's a lockdown or
something it might be a lockdown I
remember doing that for the alien there
was three things that he had to turn off
before for the alien to be locked in
there but I don't know if that was
necessary locate and help him
mmm okay yeah good thing I got plenty of
those here's another one of the lockdown
new daddies there's another one just
over there I don't that flashlight a bit
too much but I mean heck it's about time
that I had a chance to use it before
Oh where'd I go there so what is that oh
that's a terminal overview spawn I can't
get here I can't get near it why can't I
get oh okay
so whoa I didn't even notice you Jesus
Christ what the hell Jesus guys are just
douche holes everywhere non-stop across
the board
reformat chamber spitting I've sent up
some black androids for the VIP svet
Simone sale tour if you haven't done it
before just have them lie on the slab in
the reformat chamber I'll connect to
Apollo and upgrade them with the latest
programming
let's hope they bike haha Russell so
someone to this intention yeah I think
someone intentionally sabotage did at
the possible worst timing unless
someone's trying to collect like
insurance on CSUN which yo it could be
totally plausible if someone was trying
to wreck the whole [ __ ] make it seem
like a disaster happened then I could
see how someone could very easily
collect a lot of money on a loss of an
investment
everything went terribly I guess they
just didn't predict that the no no no
this dude what are you doing alive
that's a problem for me it's also a
problem for you because you're about to
end up very much on the floor and in
pieces thank you goodbye
yay chargebacks I need to hidden like
almost out of stuff to craft like I've
used everything I can't even make a
medkit not that I'm full but
I guess that's a good thing at least I'm
stocked up for a possible boss fight I
wonder if that was enough power to knock
down that I can open the other thing I
had to knock down a bunch of those
things so that I can lower the power
level enough such that god I need to
stop using my flashlight I need to do
that so that I can activate or
deactivate this one and then non
electrify the door yes I can do that now
okay we're all good huh I'm so strong
I'm so strong whatever weird futuristic
power system they use is no match for
Ripley jr. look at me look at Ripley gee
why well that's electrifying now that's
no good I find that right then I'll have
to find a way to talk to Apollo directly
I don't have time like this
nice good job Samuels well done
hey Samuels body friend hey friend oh
guy you can protect me in these troubles
sometimes please come back why didn't I
call for him Ripley come on that was
your moment does your one true moment to
declare your love for robots robosexuals
everywhere would have been delighted
fine Sam just found him I can't I
couldn't spell hey Mills
wait up for me I'm gonna be right there
it's me Ripley we're best buddies trying
to find use button good job Ripley you
sure use that oh hi you're staring
awfully dead hey Dad I don't like
mannequins don't like him that body
comes alive if this turns into real dead
space here and zombies are gonna kill me
I don't like it I'm getting reports from
downstairs about an normal BAM right
behavior it might have something to do
with all those folks going missing I
need you to get to the showroom and shut
yourself in there's a lockdown button
near my desk with from where these
machines were actually worth something
don't worry about them they're only
display models just sit tight I'll sort
this out and we can celebrate the deal
finally going through when we're not on
company time okay Spedding I'm expecting
to be out here to get here early so I
want you and your people ready and
waiting to greet them the clock's
ticking down it is our last chance to
salvage something from this piece of
[ __ ] I want you and your people to
answer every whim every voice and laugh
at every one of their [ __ ] jokes take
them to the showroom when they're ready
don't rush them and don't bore them with
speeches if they say they want something
change in the working Joe's just say yes
we can let the tech-heads worry about it
later I hope you have your best people
on this okay that went wonderfully oh
boy no appointments everything is going
lovely for this business I hear that
it's not the Skinner of an alien baby oh
I didn't even think about that
well if there are alien babies around
here what if these creepy ass mannequins
come alive door locks where am I
supposed to go then
okay so there's an air duct that oh well
I didn't know there was an air duct that
goes that way but that doesn't help me
at all does it help me I'll get back
there
Android disposal I got to go all the way
back no that can't be right there's got
to be some other alternate route don't
go here because that doesn't make any
sense cuz I would have what was the
point of coming over here with these
find a way Allison why am I locked in
what do you mean he's gonna happen find
a way out I found a way out I guess oh
here we go
let's lock down okay I did not see this
button before so that would save a lot
of time for me wandering around like an
idiot so okay the doors open now now I
can meander my way out was still nothing
okay you wanna hear it come at me one
last time you're supposed to not be
let me just like my time
whereas effect you [ __ ] you for great
us for yes
yeah no no not okay no not okay no no no
not okay that sounds bad
well the holds a sound so I guess
diverted that's the thing I did is that
them banging on the door they actually
in there doing something cool I'm gonna
I'm gonna leave now that guy's dead but
at least he's got a shotgun
lots of stuff he died get so many
shotgun shells shotgun shells up there's
a whole bunch of stuff here what they
prepping me for war good lordy Lou these
guys all died they had a stockpile for
an army EMP mines everything good golly
Miss Molly there's a lot of something so
why do I need it
am I gonna be fighting something that's
gonna require a lot of bullets am I
gonna be finally taking the fight to
this old alien man or is this Apollo
needs to shooting up because I had
plenty plenty plenty to give him lots of
pieces of my mind thrown his way I guess
this is just a storeroom that those guys
that said they were gonna get everyone
out alive went to no why would I I don't
need more of these but I can build more
so that's good I guess I'm all full up
let's find out what they had to think
before they died
least I can do that for them what do you
mean you shut down the access door to
the elevator all your guns and supplies
mean jack [ __ ] to me when the synthetic
that was chasing you is still [ __ ]
know there I think it's see me I don't
think I see me staring at your old
magazines in the blood plant overlook
blood plant get back down there down
here and open this door now looky I
don't know how many of you are still
getting around to get this but I've got
weapons and supplies and I'm setting up
shop outside the synthetic showroom I'm
hoping we'll be safe from the creature
up here Smyth is with me and waiting to
be led up from the fluid plant reception
a seven scene Suzanne if you're with her
let me know
I don't think anyone is alive okay so I
got a lot of supplies but other than
that what the hell am I supposed to do
I'm pretty much maxed out on everything
yeah they give me a lot of EMP mines but
I don't have anything to do oh did I do
that I guess with my gas flow I lit them
the [ __ ] up this is what that's for to
second that is creepy as [ __ ] okay I
need to start shooting reload reload
reload reload reload reload come this
way don't come both ways you think I got
to hold it down to reload all of them
you think this would always I got to
make sure that all the shells go
directly into your synthetic bastard
brain thank you for shopping please go
in forever no oh maybe one of them did
cuz that makes sense given that they
were show robots the business practices
of these bastards I just don't
appreciate
where did the first one died because he
probably had it I mean I let him on fire
but all that did was make him look cool
so yes I was so pretty
I want space so badly if they had or
ever had a program for people to make a
pilgrimage to Mars I would be the first
in line for that sucker I would go there
I didn't care if I would die I want to
go there so thank you kicker yes thank
you
someone finally had it I'm dead serious
I would love to be the first person to
go to Mars I don't even care if the ship
blows up halfway through just the fact
that I would be able to have a chance
pioneer the final frontier oh I want so
badly
okay thank you I'm gonna turn this off
for some reason I just have a bad habit
of turning off of everything I see I'm
like the guys that first panics when all
this [ __ ] went down they decided that it
would be a good idea to turn off
everything if you're dead you died I
turned off your power oh now the door is
open follow Samuels well where is he
where'd Samuels go Rudy yo what is
Apollo secure transit get me to where
does this go to Android orientation well
that sounds fun but that doesn't seem
where he's going well I mean hey it
might be a side mission or something I
don't know how many side missions I've
actually done maybe unintentionally I
don't have to go unless I'm not supposed
to go here yet but there was a freaking
x-wing summertime I think how am I
supposed to ignore it it's a beautiful
shiny exclamation marks it just says
hardwire get back on track you idiot
don't come this way and I just have to
follow it cuz I'm a dumb-dumb okay
jog on elephants
well I guess there was no point in
company this might be my way back cuz
that looks like the area that had all
the things where the guys start shooting
at me and I started shooting back in
self-defense of course not intentionally
being a psychopathic murderer but with
the full intention of self defending
myself don't look at me like I'm crazy
you're crazy for thinking I'm crazy how
dare you it's just been a long day I've
been recording a lot of videos so things
are good that poor tonight my bad way
too much caffeine I'm just a little bit
off but that makes for a good content
good high-quality entertainment for all
of you to enjoy mmm a wait I can't go
that way then how am I supposed to go
the way I need to go
maybe I that wouldn't be the right way
either I might as well hit the save
point again just in case but there's got
all over their sales agreement didn't I
go that way no that's the way I came in
so that means maybe I wasn't supposed to
go up there and I was supposed to do
something to fix it and I just have
bailed out like a doof oh I'm such a
doof unless there's some way I'm
supposed to go back no I need to restore
about there must have wood oh there must
have been something else
mmm-hmm cuz these are currently not in
service so I need to find a way to get
these over here
transportation lockdown act so how do I
turn down the lockdown hey where do I go
to turn off the lockdown Samuels has
gone to seasoned synthetic in order to
reach Apollo and ask it to cancel the
heightened lockdown locate him there and
help him okay I'm gonna go back up the
elevator because I have a feeling that
that's the only way I can go ergo that
should be where I do go so I need to do
go down and do go my way to the place
where I don't know what else to I'm just
wandering around spouting nonsense out
of my mouth is what I do for most of my
career which is doing quite well for me
thank you guys so much for enduring my
endless streams of bull okay let's try
this again with less bad ah see there
was a way I just didn't do it
I had to go the manual route I didn't
even bother to check I just thought it
was a side route all please do not tell
me
I need to time this for the air blast
I'm not good at this I was happy huh
it's gonna blow hey it's gonna blow me
borrow don't be to blow me so I need to
wait the next one
what kind of factory would have this
periodic fan [ __ ] going on here why
what what engineer would design it this
way and why just in case someone who's
gonna walk by and even I need to make
sure it blows people at these exact
moments with superheated steam tonight
clear to go or what all right
hello you look into sting and blowing
ensuing I need to get to you okay cuz
that one's permanent okay that was so
far it hurts so bad okay
sad eyes
okay here we go jump you've done worse
Ripley stop trying to make a drama out
of it you're perfectly fine
well maybe I'm tired I've been through a
lot and have not slept therefore it
would be reasonable to understand that
so where am I going now what am i doing
now why am i doing it for what purpose
am I here
why must I go through these endless
turmoils what fresh hell have I been
thrust into that's how Ripley sounds
relax she's just pretending for
everybody else you got the movie trailer
voice in a world where everything is
trying to kill me but no one is as
badass as Ripley jr. I what is that
what's going on here there's just a
rendering bug again
was that something for realsies okay so
this is gonna go some weird way that's
probably gonna help me find Sam
I don't know how am I supposed to know
how's anybody supposed to an endless
series of tubes just like the internet
was that no no I heard some wow this is
just a secret area
I just forex writers okay nothing there
unless there was I must have been one of
the doors on the little alcoves on the
map on the left side so I must walk
along that wall until I find door that
will accept me for who I am
organ storage really Android organ
storage I'm guessing I don't want I
don't know what kind of organs oh okay
there was okay my bad I did not see this
I was praying at the same point did not
did I see
I saved in IKEA I saved don't know I bet
if that gets me it's gonna activate
every Android in this room you didn't
see nothing no what hmm indeed it's so
weird my fin thetic sensors there
detective
I thought I saw hey come over here I got
something to tell you
no sorry I was mistake but I did
actually didn't have something how about
no could I say no to that could you have
a execute seems to be easier just to
take you out with the chocolate so I'm
gonna do this blood on me
oh you're stupid synthetic blood what is
that no one told you could join the
party hey you frickin Frick er they keep
surprising me I guess I shouldn't be
surprised I should just assume that
they're gonna be moral that better be
the last one I only have so many med
kids I think it was stuck on that body
there okay now that that crisis is over
I can continue on my way that one's
gonna get up.get okey we're fine is
there anything over there I need
probably but at least I can activate the
deep security dudes right here I could
have snuck through there very easily but
I chose not to because I am taking a
different path
thank you that was literally all I
needed I'll be on my way now
is there something cool on the inside of
this control storage no just one time
I'm gonna open one of those causes he's
gonna be like you don't belong here it's
gonna be a robot strangle me to death
so much fun so where does this event go
I'm guessing this vent is important
maybe if I was actually playing the
sneaky route it might go somewhere what
if I didn't have the talent act the
camera I would have to go through the
vents is there a point to this is there
some reason I'm supposed to go down here
and anybody know can I make another med
kit no I don't have an injector I have
everything else but not an injector oh
why is that camera still active what the
hell is that different camera I just oh
it's a series of the same room over and
over again okay I got you
so I guess if I wanted to avoid the
aliens or the robots I would just hop
from room to room they're deactivating
the sensor
I guess I've fallen I'm gonna make a run
back so I'm doing something to help not
make this a problem I have no idea I
have no idea why I'm doing this because
it's very clear
that's so weird
okay bye who's gonna go on my way
Samuel Zeke really could have killed all
these guys before I got here I just need
to do it - one more oh the box isn't
over here good
exactly what I didn't want should be
bye-bye everybody
I don't think that one has a head don't
you dare
I heard that was a bleep on my motion
sensor someone's up someone woke up
hurry up pretty the Freak up hurry up I
like how they're called wards
there's a security ward the same Ward
special needs somebody I am over your
okay I'm assuming I'm okay
Tammy Mills Daniels thanks
okay I'm listening what do you need to
do I'm really listening I'm trying to be
my best listener right now hi Samuels
where the hell did you come from what
are you doing now you told me to listen
okay that was green but I like a second
ago so what is the point of this why
don't we just get off this place and
blow it all up let everyone on their own
everyone's probably dead already
let's just get out of here save our
skins and go home dad just make a big
circle I feel like I just went in a
giant circle and this didn't they mean
no good that Samuels Oh Here I am
that's too dangerous Samuels no no my
robot buddy
the one robot who really understood me
Samuel no don't go Wow speedy I didn't
see the bad move
amazing yeah what I need to do yellow
blue red red red red right
katar the thing they made it easy
like I'm diffusing a bomb
my brain
much better not be some hostile takeover
of Apollo on your end
whoa I have become the ship now Ripley
I have merged consciousness I'm coming
for you baby card oh if you're there
pick up they so said Samuels is gone
he opened Apollo transit for me I'm
gonna go straight there
I'll get Apollo to lift the lockdown
that's so sad come on so sad
Samuels you were actually cool captain
whatever you robot bastards I'll blast
you all to hell Chloe will run robot
it's Dan plays that I liked didn't
something - shut up I won't follow you
know where cuz I'm gonna I'm gonna beat
you to death just cuz I feel like you
deserve this Samuels was way better than
you every damn it
damn this game for making me care about
a character god damn it badass not a be
happy about that
ok so where do I need to go follow take
private transit to Apollo Cory looks
like this is where I am but I don't see
I don't see any private transit here
must be something down there I guess I
have no idea that's just so sad bombing
this the bun use a cool character I mean
it's good to the story I guess Dan I'm
all sad now legitimately I am
okay so where the hell did they go I
heard it so that was when the Android
struck I'm guessing I still didn't see
the body of weights maybe it was just in
one of those guys have no idea come on
that's right come on hurry up I don't
have all day hey des how about like that
come on about three thought you so slow
I thought this is supposed to be a
private transport some from luxury oh
okay I guess think I'm approaching the
end of this game I have no idea I think
I'm getting to the point where like I
don't know I don't know how much is left
in the game
whoo space keep moving slowly and
carefully I just got a feel feel it's
good for bad guys gain direct access
okay that's cool so what am i or what
are we gonna talk about the weather
recipes sports games things like that
things of that nature I have no idea
what to talk about I'm bad at small talk
no sister Brambling oh I'm gonna bore
them to death together tomorrow citizens
journey into colonial space an official
history
yeah they're obsessed with hazard
containment because of the freakin alien
the alien is bad news bonkers oh come on
I didn't even care oh not my
flamethrower - you're taking my weapons
aren't you bye-bye babies see you soon
they took samples away from me they took
away my blades oh my baby
this game is cruel this game as cruel as
cruel can be so now what I'm good thank
you
thank you oh come on why the lanes
blocked off okay the schematics are here
we go okay
there's a power conduit that links to
the apollo core values that turn off the
electrics take some deep breaths
squeeze easy good to know you got my
back
thanks Ricardo how did you survive the
Android attack by the way that's what
I'd like
maybe he's it then that it is a coup
he's one of them robos okay so I need to
find a way to get around and oh wait no
I just got the passcode that's it that
was the passcode to this door okay I got
it I got it so it was four nine three
zero all righty then we're making I'll
have to power it down first yeah that's
the idea door Ricardo for a daughter
dumb-dumb am i right I'm the smart one
okay so anyway mom all the time for this
episode things are getting interesting
and I feel like I'm close to the end the
extra the other are the next hour long
episode maybe the last one in this
series which would be pretty cool so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next one
oh yeah don't wanna just this is gonna
be a problem for you one man one bullet
Baba still step reverse nah I'm still
with this don't go